this morning I introduced the idea of
inequalities and I said here's a whole
bunch of properties as a whole bunch of
properties here are three kind of main
techniques you can use to solve
questions like these right do you
remember what the three techniques were
after we listed all the properties for
the three you can start with a property
you start with a property you can write
it down just like you go right down the
binomial theorem and then you just sort
of work from there to the required
result that was number one option two
was you could assume that the result
they what is wrong right and then use
some logic and then come up with a
contradiction proof by contradiction the
third method was to employ calculus
what was the what's the give away that
tells you you really should use calculus
on a question like this it's a good way
it's where you've got non algebraic
functions like for example of log okay
so I want to show you this question we
did one with a derivative before like we
used it to show there's a decrease in
function therefore prefer such as such a
function is always lower than zero that
got us to the unit quality we want to
have a look at this guy okay now they
will give you a lead-in
they won't they were just give you this
inequality cold okay because there are
just so many options for where you could
go but leading here is pretty small bone
by considering the curve y equals 1 and
X proved that this is less than this
okay so what do you think about using
differentiation or integration one of
the things that will help you here and
I've just sort of taken out part of this
to help you is this sometimes very
frequently actually you'll get a
three-part inequality you get a chain of
inequalities okay now the reason why if
you've got something here is less than
something assessing something else okay
well that's why I indicated to you is
you've got an exact area under a curve
below that you can make some kind of
polygon like a trapezium and above that
you can also make another polygon which
are kind of like your upper and lower
boundaries right and then you can use
that to make approximations or whatever
the thing in the
now if that is the case you just have to
treat each of the inequalities
individually like there's two of them
and then you just solve but in this case
I'm just giving you one half of the
chain and let's see how we can work with
this
yeah we've got curve y equals 1 on X and
many here you've got like some balls and
some xmas ones and X minus 1 okay so I'm
thinking that already here if I
designate some value like here has X X
minus 1 and X plus 1 FP here as my two
points just before and just after it's
arbitrary X value okay so I'm just going
to draw here so what I've got is my X
take away 1 and my X plus 1 now I wonder
if you can see how given these
boundaries this expression here would
emerge think about it the relationship
between 1 and X to get to log of course
is where you do to get from one to the
other you're going to integrate and you
can see in here if you just kind of
think I'd be a bit steep like look at
this thing
log laws will tell me that I would write
this as log of X plus 1 takeaway log of
X minus 1 do you agree right so what you
can think of is hey hey hey these are
upper and lower balance right you see
how you've got one value take away the
other so I think this M plus 1 is X
minus 1 there bit to me the boundaries
of an integral that I'm gonna fall so
what I've got is this guy I'll use a
different color
this area underneath the curve this is
going to be part of it
and then you can see that's supposed to
be less than something else this less
than something else okay so what I want
is well what's the simplest kind of
shape that I know has to be greater than
my green area and the most common
theorem come up is a trapezium like that
okay because like I could make it more
complicated but why this is nice than
simple and actually gets us pretty close
depending on what the captures sir have
a look at it it's a trapezium and what
piece of admission do you need to go to
work out the area which piece in there
three of them okay I need the I need the
perpendicular height where you have a
look at this the perpendicular head is
between the parallel sides right so it's
this length what is it it's just -
because you weren't one this way one
that way in addition to the
perpendicular height you also need to
know yeah good
these guys here in other words thinking
about that trapezoidal rule I need two
function values yeah now this is a nice
easy function and I also have a pretty
simple values to put in right
so I think that this length here is
going to be 1 over to this value and
this one here is going to be 1 over X
minus 1 okay I think I've done enough
pre-work I think I'm ready I'm going to
form an inequality now off the basis of
this geometry this reason that I've just
done okay so one area less than another
how would you like me to write the
integral
from way to win blow about to upper
bound
what's the function that I'm integrating
just like just one of X and I'm going
belted to the x-axis so that's just
reinforce strategy X ok so over here the
right hand side I've got the area of a
trapezium so this is H or - that's
202 by the way it is prude so even
though it's equal to 1 I'm going to say
- 1 - because I'm showing I know
everything comes from it - trapezium -
or 2 times a plus B yeah there's two
guys ok
so set up my inequality and really that
was the hardest part of this looking
into the question and without me helping
you how would you think how'd you fall
ok this is the diagram I need these are
the things are gonna relate my pieces
together so every time the left let's
just integrate it's log X I've already
got my mama and my papa balance now I'm
gonna start simplifying we know this
will become 1 what we're doing inside
the brackets suggestion call it
cognitive over there
so that's going to become X plus 1 is
the plus X minus 1 will over the common
denominator which is X square take away
1 oh that's promising
so faster good I'm going to evaluate
this tributed function now so I've got a
log of X plus 1 log
- one book it good yeah what's happening
on this new rail that's just two x's and
that the ones are gonna cancel and then
you're pretty much there this is what I
wanted I just need to combine these two
and so it's actually quite hassle-free
right so in a similar way to what it was
like with your right to change questions
right the calculus is not the hard part
of this the calculus is quite
straightforward in the geometry is quite
straightforward but the hard part is
draw a picture
what however for this once you get to
that line I think the message is down
your so make sense